that your time is under pressure which
means our time is under pressure if you
want to leave on time please don't ask
please don't give long answers we'll
keep the questions short if you keep the
answer short and then we'll get you out
on time but if you are too well briefed
and you have too many statistics we will
have to detain you so please keep to the
point we will crack straight on with our
first topic which is um on international
issues starting with the war in Ukraine
Alyssa occurs thank you yeah prime
minister if I may I will take you around
the world as many questions as I have
time for
um you've ordered a Goldman Sach star
review of UK support for Ukraine the
media say this a sign you'll be less
steadfast in your support for our
Ukrainian allies the defense chair and I
would like you to commit today to
unreserved support for Ukraine no matter
the outcome of this audit
yes I wouldn't necessarily read too much
into the Press reports
look at my actions I'd say first of all
the first foreign call I made was to
president zielinski the first bilateral
foreign trip I made was to Kiev I've
spoken to president zelenski probably a
couple more times since then also
organized for him to speak to the G7
leaders also the Jeff leaders yesterday
where I was at the Jeff Summit and
committed to maintaining or increasing
our military support to Ukraine next
year so those are all the actions today
in the seven or eight weeks that I've
been in office of course we will
continue to support Ukraine I think both
what all of us would want to see is
Ukraine successfully repel Russian
aggression then it's important that we
maintain support but also evolve the
support for the conditions that we're
seeing on the ground in the battlefield
and that's what I'm Keen to do thank you
turning to Russia's backers in Iran
Obama's greatest regret from his time in
power was not what was listening to his
advisors when they told him not to back
the Green Revolution in Iran today the
jcpoa is failing the women of Iran kind
of being brutalized Iran's committing
assassinations across Europe and
perpetrating war crimes in Ukraine how
are you standing by the people of Iran
and will you now sanction the Islamic
revolutionary guard Corps as you
promised in the leadership competition
over the summer
I think the protests that we're seeing
in Iran send a very clear message that
the Iranian people aren't satisfied with
the path that the government has taken
uh We Stand very much with the people of
Iran I think the treatment of protesters
is quite frankly abhorrent that's why
the in terms of actions this year the
foreign secretary summoned the senior
Iranian official here to express our
view to them and then over the course of
three different days on the 9th of
December the 14th of November and the
10th of October we've sanctioned over
almost 40 different individuals
connected with the protests including
the so-called morality police and on the
14th of December we together with
International allies kicked Iran out of
the U.N Commission on the status of
women and on the IRG specifically yeah
so we already sanctioned the irgc in its
entirety and typically we wouldn't
comment on a conscription album
prescription
I I believe you've prescribed them but
not sanctioned them
yeah we we sanctioned the irgc in its
entirety uh the separate list of
terrorist organizations that are
purposes kept under review and we
generally wouldn't comment on
descriptions
um why won't you comment
because we wouldn't comment on processes
that may or may not be underway
it's a frustrating foreign office Quirk
um the security services have rightly
identified China as our greatest
National Security challenge but we have
no strategic coherence on this we have
fallen short putting forward key
resilient strategies we've failed to
protect refugees on British soil from
Chinese Diplomat brutality you promised
to change the China policy on day one if
you made prime minister so how have you
done that uh just we're going to China
just to finish on Iran it's worth saying
whilst Russia and Ukraine remains our
number one foreign policy uh challenge
as we go into the new year I am
increasingly concerned uh about Iran's
Behavior the treatment of their citizens
their Regional
you know what I'd say you know that what
they're doing in the region which is
destabilizing and indeed the nuclear
program so I think it's something that
we'll need to spend increasing amount of
time on uh going forward now with regard
to China again
um I I would just say looking I've been
doing this seven or eight weeks and if
we just look very practically at the
steps that we've taken in that time I've
always been clear that China represents
um you know systematic challenge to our
values has very different values to ours
but what matters is the actions that we
are taking and there's a handful first
and foremost we use the powers under the
National Security and investment act to
block The increased stake in Newport
wafer Fab secondly when it came to the
decision to Green Light size well we
ensure that the Chinese State nuclear
company was no longer going to be a part
of that project and thirdly and specific
we've removed surveillance from the hmgs
state which is connected with the
National Intelligence law in China and
then most recently as well we've um
we've had organized 50 other countries
in the U.N for a resolution in the
committee regarding xinjiang those are
all concrete steps in just the last
seven or eight weeks that we have taken
which I think demonstrates my commitment
to stand up to China where it's in our
interest
so where that takes us back to your
policy of robust pragmatism how does our
dependence on China how much does that
keep you up at night when rowing up your
ability to be robust rather than just
pragmatic
yeah so I mean the actions I just
outlined are all robust actions we
talked about resilience and that that's
why we didn't think it was appropriate
for
the Newport the Newport wafer fast
transaction to go ahead as planned we
blocked it that's why we've removed the
surveillance technology from the HMG
instead that's why we've removed a cgn
from the size of our project those are
examples of robust action to protect
us again it's economic and other threats
yeah all I'd say is it's also important
that our approach to China is aligned
with our closest allies having discussed
it with President Biden indeed the prime
ministers of Japan and Australia I
believe that our policy is aligned and
there will be many things that we do
have to have a dialogue with China on
whether that's Global Public Health
climate change or the macro economy it
makes sense to do that and very finely
chair we seem to have a real issue tying
down our policy when it comes to our
relationship with turkey they've been an
important conduit between Europe and
Russia over the last few months but
since 2019 erdogan has carried out
attack after attack on the Kurdish
people he's now claiming he's going to
roll in the tanks to eradicate them
this could a jeopardize our success
against daesh and B C atrocities
prevented on mass so what is HMG doing
under your leadership to step in to
deter turkey from undertaking these
heinous attacks I I've spoken to the
president both the international Summit
we were both that but also bilaterally
as well we'll continue to use all our
offices uh to encourage turkey to do the
right thing and most recently we work
constructively with them on ensuring the
grain for the great Black Sea grain deal
was renewed and that was something that
they helped play a part in thank you a
couple of questions quickly with my uh
it is of course astonishing that we
allowed China to carry on doing what
they were doing for so long and we're
certainly I'm certainly with one pleased
with the direction the government's
taking but coming back to Russia
um the defense actually made a statement
this afternoon pointing out this is the
300th day of the war that was meant to
take a few days and has been militarily
disastrous for Russia but are we
underestimating their will what do you
make of Russian willpower because they
are putting everything into the fight
the Russian doctrine of of Total War and
victory at any cost seems to be very
apparent
yeah and that's why it's important that
we continue to maintain and increase our
support to Ukraine and make sure that
that support is effective in deterring
further Russian aggression and pushing
them back from the territory that
they've already seized and that's what
we'll continue to do how much is that as
shared as deeply as you
with our European allies at that and
that's why I was at the Jeff Summit
yesterday about 10 countries very
like-minded on values but particularly
with regard to the threat that Russia
poses and again very strong consensus
about what we need to do next year
whether it's a specific type of Military
Support needed those are the types of
things we discussed yesterday and those
conversations I've had more broadly as
well and the defense chair if he was
here would be asking
what's happened to the Lessons Learned
document in the ministry of Defense
about
Lessons Learned on the Ukraine conflict
particularly about replenishing our
Munitions which the defense secretary
with said will be replenished or are
being replenished and of course the
resilience of our munition supply chains
which are have turned out to be very
thread better what are we doing about
that it needs money
uh yes and we are replenishing our
Munitions I think as the defense sector
probably acknowledge as you just
acknowledged as well Bernard the issue
is less money than it is supply chain
capacity in the short term that is the
challenge I mean that is that is a
gating or limiting factor on our ability
to get some of the support we'd like to
see flowing to Ukraine happening quicker
but one thing you know at the point
right at the beginning is we need to
make sure that we get them what they
need the priorities at the moment are
air defense armored vehicles and
artillery and Munitions the contract
that we've just signed 250 million
pounds will ensure that there's a ready
supply of artillery next year but also
on a monthly basis the Ukraine can plan
with certainty which they haven't always
been able to do because of the supply
chain our contract that we've put in
place will give them that certainty and
reliability next year which will be
helpful thank you Clive Betts for
leveling up committee uh thank you chair
um good afternoon prime minister I'm
going to talk about the situation with
Ukrainian refugees in this country I'm
sure all our thoughts this Christmas
will be with our Ukrainian guests and
particularly children who are going to
be spending Christmas in a foreign
country thinking of their loved ones
back in Ukraine and also thanks to the
wonderful hosts who've hosted a hundred
thousand Ukrainian individuals in our
country unfortunately uh 3 000 Ukrainian
families have presented themselves as
homeless in the last six months and many
of those families including children
will spend Christmas in temporary
accommodation is that really acceptable
prime minister we should get to that
situation in a wealthy country like we
are well I think first thing to say as
you did I was to express our gratitude
and admiration for the thousands of
British families who have opened up
their hearts and homes to accommodate
Ukrainian refugees
previously many of them will be selling
an extra place at their Christmas table
um in a week's time and that is
enormously to their credit now the way
that we did this was through the homes
for Ukraine scream as you know and that
was with sponsor families taking people
in the announcement that we made just
recently extends the thank you payments
to those families for a further 12
months also increases them from 350
pounds a month to 500 pounds a month and
and to your other point we've provided I
think about 150 million pounds funding
two local authorities to help mitigate
homelessness at in the second year well
it will mitigate it certainly won't
solve the problem of homeless refugees
because we've got the Afghan refugees as
well on top of that but you mentioned
the the payments to sponsors
um Richard Harrington when he was
Minister said that this payment should
be doubled
um you know last week the government
announced an increase from 350 to 500
pounds
um a month for families but only after
one year
on the committee we've met Ukrainian a
host of Ukrainian families who are
thinking about giving up after six
months and the pressure of the cost of
living is one of those issues promise
that can't you just be a bit more
generous increase the payments a bit
more and bring them forward to stop
homelessness increasing amongst refugees
it's worth bearing in mind that it's not
just payments to the families that the
government is making it's also payments
to local authorities as you'll be
familiar there's a tariff of over ten
thousand pounds which has meant over a
billion pounds of funding has also been
flowing to local authorities to help
them with preparations but the housing
secretary has also made available half a
billion pounds in funding for a local
Authority housing fund to that's for
Capital funding to areas that are facing
a significant housing pressure as a
result of Ukrainian arrivals and that
will help alleviate some of the
pressures that we're seeing we're also
enabling a rematching scheme where
Ukrainian guests can find new sponsors
after their initial six months and we're
providing guidance in both the Ukrainian
and Russian to help households access
the private rental sector we just
mentioned the help deliver some of these
prime minister which was ten and a half
thousand pounds per person per year
but you've just cut it from Germany the
first to five thousand nine hundred
pounds for new arrivals so if if ten
thousand five hundred pounds was the
right figure uh this year why is only
five thousand hundred pounds the right
figure next year well it's a it's a
combination of things first of all there
are some costs that are front loaded
you'll know that speaking to local
authorities uh but also it's a question
of what we can afford across the board
as as alluded to the beginning this is
all going on for longer than people have
anticipated we want to increase some of
the payments to individual families
providing shelter your first questions
are about not making sure that those
families are homeless or put in
temporary accommodation so we've
increased those payments um but I think
it's reasonable over time that payments
of local authorities change also worth
bearing in mind that we have provided
six and a half billion pounds in extra
funding that will be made available to
local government more generally as a
result of the Autumn statement so that
is new funding going into local
government which I assume we'll talk
about soon too question yes but as a
next local government Minister you'll
know that local councils have had bigger
cuts to their budgets than any other
part in the public sector over the last
12 years so there's a cut to the amount
of money local authorities are going to
receive for the sponsored families uh
the authorities get nothing at all to
refugees who come under the family
scheme though they have to buy all the
services including Children's Services
as well so why should local citizens
through their councils have to have Cuts
further cuts to their libraries their
bus services their street sweeping
services for what is is an international
and a national problem shouldn't it be
central government that picks up this
costs and not local councils central
government is picking up no the
chocolate amount of the costs the local
government as
for the last two years has been going up
a very significant level but why no
money for the family scheme at all prime
minister I mean there is there is
considerable overall funding going into
this there's no money for the family
scheme at all overall into local
government there's six and a half
there's no money for a family scheme at
all I think
I think okay um
came down to Johnson
from the home Affairs Select Committee
important to small boats which was
published in the summer it was clear
that the Asylum back blog had been
allowed to grow since 2013 and was an
Achilles heel really in its weakness and
undermining everything else so the top
recommendation in our report was to
clear the backlog 13th of December at
you say to Parliament we expect to
abolish the backlog of initial Asylum
Decisions by the end of next year so a
really bold claim can you just confirm
the number that you plan to abolish by
the end of next year yes it's um it's
the initial Asylum backlog with up to
June the 28th which is when the NADA
came into effect which separated the
pool of Asylum Seekers and remember it's
90 something thousand so it's 92 000 not
the 120 000 that we currently have in
117 000 was the total number at the time
I made the statement but that is
comprised of the 92 which is the
prejudes at which point the nabba
separates and distinguishes so it's not
actually abolishing the backlog is it
it's abolishing well look if we can go
further but it's not abolishing I think
that's the key I think it would
represent one of the most significant
reduction in the backlog that we've seen
and I said if we can go further I'd
absolutely like to right okay how many
small boats do you envisage will be
coming into the UK in 2023 I I I I
wouldn't I it wouldn't impossible for me
to put a precise number on it I've been
very clear that this problem is not an
easy one to solve it's complicated and
it can't be solved overnight but what I
do know is that the steps that we are
taking already and we intend to take
will make a difference okay so so the
home office this year we're planning for
up to 60 000 people to come across in
small bows but you're saying there isn't
a figure for next year uh I don't have
it to hand that I thought I'm sure there
is a planning figure but you're asking
me what I think will actually happen
there's a reasonable worst case scenario
that they plan to do which is different
to what I can precisely tell you will
happen because obviously that'll be a
function of many things what do you
expect the backlog to be in December 23
then
I said it's a function of of arrivals
which are uncertain but I can tell you
the initial Asylum backlog is what we're
keen to clear over the course of next
year and we'll do that by tripling the
productivity of our case yes I'd like to
ask you about that but do you think that
anyone will be waiting for more than six
months at the end of next year to have
their respect I think as well as
clearing the initial Asylum backlog what
we're keen to do is look at the
end-to-end process it takes us to
process
and see how we can train that and that I
think will actually as I've made the
point before at the moment that the
process is such that it can be used by
people to extend it and stretch it out
and I want to make sure that that system
isn't being interviews or exploited and
that's some of the legislative changes
that will look can I just press you then
about what you've said which is that
you're going to in order to clear the
the backlog you're going to double the
workforce you're going to Triple
productivity and you're going to
re-engineer the system so what I know is
the home office struggle when they make
targets for themselves and I am worried
that there's some kind of fairy tale
figures in this
they fail to meet their target of
getting a thousand caseworkers in 2021
46 of caseworkers left in 2021 the pilot
the home office had produced to increase
productivity went from 1.2 decisions per
week per case worker to up to 2.7 per
case worker per week
the it systems are poor and in the
judges in the Rwanda case just yesterday
talked about the poor Administration and
the home office so I wondered what
evidence you've actually used to base
your Target on of being able to to
reduce the the Asylum backlog two things
one is we have already doubled the case
working Workforce over the past 12
months so that's one proof point and the
second is we've taken an extensive
exercise to map the process end to end
and on the basis of a bunch of modeling
that has been done that's relatively
sophisticated that's where the estimate
of a tripling of the productivity comes
from okay so I only know about the pilot
that the home office has been running
but there's something else that they've
been doing then well see when I when I
set up I said we had looked at the
entire process end to end okay and
identified steps in the process that we
think we can streamline remove or tweak
and on the basis of modeling that you
would expect to do when you're doing
systems engineering that's what gives
you the trip okay let's hope the home
office and that can actually achieve
that so I just want to ask you about
Rwanda what's the actual Target for how
many people you're planning to send to
Rwanda by the end of 23. well I I think
we expect further legal challenge will
continue to pursue that as necessary and
it's one of the many things that we want
to teach you you don't have a figure
the Rwandan government are talking about
200. I think we haven't commented on
what is a commercial contract and
rightly so but what we're keen to do is
have a system which we move to whereas
if someone comes here illegally they
don't have the right to stay and we have
the right to remove them Commander is a
part of that as will new legislation be
and I I welcome the fact that the court
recognize that the policy is uh what's
the budget that you've done last
question what's the budget you've
allocated for the Rwanda policy
we've said clearly that there's 120
million pound payment for economic
development that's already been paid
additional 20. so 140 that's it there's
no more money
there's there's nothing else that we've
said publicly or will in a commercial
and just very finely if I could just ask
do you think the opponent secretary was
right to actually say there was no
evidence of value for money with the
Rwanda scheme I I believe the Rwanda
scheme represents an important part of
our plan to test clinical migration and
stops more votes it's not the only part
of it but it's an important part of it
that's why I welcome the court decision
yesterday
thank you very good prime minister
you've said that um uh the aim is that
anybody who arrives here illegally will
not stay here
um and some lawyers are advising you
that that can be done without setting
aside any aspects of the echr or the
Human Rights Act others are saying it
cannot be done how are you going to
judge that question because if you take
the wrong advice and they keep arriving
and staying that won't add much
credibility to your objective
as I said we'll introduce legislation in
the new year which will achieve the aim
that I set out and the legislation is
one part of an overall plan that I set
out to Parliament recently and I'm
confident that we can deliver on that
plan and it will make a difference and
reduce the number of votes arriving
and on the question of the echr I think
we'll introduce legislation in the new
year which will deliver on the system
that I said I would
anybody else want to follow that one up
um Philip Dunn
prime minister I'm going to ask you some
questions about your government's
environmental commitments and how you're
going to deliver them following the
conclusion of the cop 27 conference
which I was pleased you attended I asked
you on the floor of the house how you
were going to personally ensure that as
the structures for cop26 were dismantled
with the teams and structures of
government changing how are we going to
deliver our national determine
contributions and you said you would
personally drive it through government
you're not chairing the one cabinet
committee that had some direct
responsibility for this so how are you
doing that
I take a couple of things but first of
all that that cabinet committee those
decisions still come to me as part of
the Collective Agreement process so I
think ultimately I'm the ultimate
decision maker and the second thing the
number 10 team are intimately involved
in all aspects of it whether that's the
um my office sitting on that committee
specifically the delivery unit the
process currently going over all the
targets we have and the policy unit
involved with departments and I think
probably the third thing I'd say is
again judgment about my actions we've
been doing it in seven or eight weeks
and in that time I've already worked
closely with cabinet ministers on
various aspects zero whether that's on
an offshore wind nuclear and indeed
Energy Efficiency where I specifically
got involved as we've been developing
policy there and making announcements
the government lost a case in the high
court in relation to its Net Zero
strategy are you involved in the review
to refresh that strategy by the end of
March yes I'll be doing that over the
Christmas holidays because we intended
obviously
respond to the high court demand and
indeed Chris skidmore's Net Zero review
ideally together and I'm going over
exactly that over the next period good
well he's a valid member of our
committee so we'll be pleased to get him
back once that works finished are you
receiving regular updates on National
determined contributions and how we're
getting on with it yes and it said I'll
be reviewing all of that with the
delivery unit again
foreign
the cop 15 Global biodiversity
conference just finished in Montreal
with which has been widely applauded our
commitments under that include
commitments to protect habitats and
species how do you intend to deliver on
those targets by 2030 yeah if I just
actually if you don't mind for them just
pay tribute to
Therese coffee and Zach Goldsmith and it
will Lockhart and the rest of the team
for their efforts something everyone
could be proud of the UK demonstrated
real leadership we did in under our cult
presidency by putting nature at the
heart of how we'll meet our climate
objectives and I think we've followed
that up in Montreal and that was
recognized by leaders around around the
world in terms of delivery on it I
there's what we will have is an
environmental Improvement plan which
will be published early in 2023 which
will mean the progress can be monitored
and the government can be held
accountable for the actions to recover
nature and we obviously have a legally
binding set of targets recently we've
published as part of our world leading
environment act and you know I'm excited
to get on and deliver that so that you
make an enormous difference and it's
something where we are you know
unequivocally leading the world in
I think we're leading the world in
designating areas both in on land and
the marine environment that we're
responsible for through our overseas
territories and around our Waters around
the UK but much less so an enforcement
there have been a lot of concerns from
ngos in particular that the enforcement
of our Regulatory Agencies lacks teeth
lacks resources and therefore lacks
enforcement are you able to respond to
that by providing more resource for
enforcement
um
well
I'm not I'm not familiar with the
specific concern I know certainly on on
water pollution and sewage for example
we've given off what considerably more
powers as part of the legislation that
we passed where they can Levy fines of
up to from memory I think 250 million
pounds um at the outset which is an
example of us beefing up The Regulators
where we think that there's a problem so
it's not something that we've shied away
from where we think
it's something I'm happy to keep an eye
on it I I don't disagree with you we
need to be able to enforce the rules
that we've set that's what we've done
with off what and if there are
look at that as I'm sure the secretary
of state would if appropriate
thank you
thank you very much uh Harriet Baldwin
on economic issues now
thank you chair
prime minister inflation is clearly the
biggest economic challenge facing our
country at the moment and the blame for
that most of it can be squarely laid out
the doors of the Kremlin
but when you were Chancellor there
clearly were inflationary pressures
emerging even more before the invasion
of Ukraine and the bank of England was
running a very loose monetary policy but
you were running a very loose fiscal
policy can you tell us what you most
regret about your time as Chancellor uh
I I actually when it comes to fiscal
policy I think I think I was getting
criticism for uh tightening fiscal
policy ahead of others because I
specifically made the point about
inflation and interest rate risk at a
time when many people were telling me I
could rely on Rock Bottom interest rates
forever and borrowing was fine and we
could spend what we liked and I didn't
think that that was right said that it
wasn't right and that's why I think in
the spring of 2020 why I talked about it
towards the end of 2020 and in Spring
2021 introduced a set of measures to
actually start putting the public
finances on a much more sustainable
track and at the time many people said
that we were the first country to do
that and it wasn't necessary so I think
on that actually I'm proud of the record
that I have no one gets these things
perfectly right I'm not pretending I did
but I I do think that we were right to
identify that as a risk and take steps
earlier than others did to start
mitigating it and you know I think in
terms of other reflects I have I the one
thing that and it was more apparent like
in hindsight that is still a tricky
thing to fix and I think it might be
that Stephen wants to talk about a bit
later is inactivity and I think that uh
it just what was going on in the labor
market
um getting caught any Everyone by
surprise and again all very well in
hindsight but at the time everyone
thought when furlough ended and things
like that there would be mass
unemployment and I was getting criticism
for ending furlough
um that wasn't the issue and the issue
was very much on the other end where the
labor market was not as large as we
would like it to be there had had we
known about that earlier I wonder if
there were things we could have done to
stop people leaving because it's always
better to stop people leaving the labor
market than to try and attract them back
once they've left I'm not sure there are
obvious answers but that's something
that clearly we need to address now but
you do know about that issue now and yet
the chancellor in the Autumn statement
announced next year's cost of living
payment of 900 pounds the committee
welcomes the fact that that has been
increased and announced but it will
apply to only those on means-tested
benefits which means that someone who
moves out of that means test and earns
one pound extra will lose 900 pounds in
terms of that cost of living payment so
that's a ridiculous Cliff Edge that
plausibly you're now baking into the
system that could act as a way in which
people could be very much
disincentivized from entering the labor
market at a higher pay and we published
a report last week on that recommending
that those Cliff edges be dealt with and
do you support our recommendations
I think when you're when you're
dispensing that type of support
either scale it's a third of all
households are in the receipt of it you
have to do things that are also
operationally deliverable and and simple
I I totally acknowledge the point like
wherever you have an eligibility
criteria that you know won't be perfect
and I think I'd probably say there's
three things one is it's not a single
payment
partly to address the concern that you
raise Harrier it's two payments split so
that straight away means that people can
who flow in and out of benefits as many
people do have um
again that's a question then on
operational delivery and what actually
is possible for DWP to administer
without having people waiting a long
time they're getting it right I think
the second thing is you can also appeal
your beneficial type and benefit
entitlement on the qualifying date and
if it's found to have been successful
you'll have a back dated payment and the
third thing is always to remember is
there is a very significant
discretionary element through the
household support fund of an extra
billion pounds which is well able and
deliberately in place to pick up those
um those hard cases so I think that
those are three you know significant
mitigations against uh the concern that
you have and nothing is going to be
perfect when you come to these things
it's just a trade-off between what's
deliverable and how do we balance the
different things that we have to
speaking of things not being perfect
baked into the Chancellor's Autumn
statement is the assumption that fuel
duty is going to rise by 12 pence in the
spring I'm sure you would want to
confirm today to the committee that
that's not going to happen having having
previously had his job I always
preferred it when the Prime Minister
made absolutely no comments about future
tax policy and so I will very much
adhere to that
you know cost of living client crisis so
you're not going to let the chancellor
get away with 12 pounds I'm going to let
the chancellor make the policy on fiscal
decisions and announce them in the
normal way well don't you think that as
someone who as you rightly point out as
Chancellor had to deal with the fact
that these are always baked into the
numbers and you have to then reverse
them that we ought to come up with a
better approach to fuel Duty now I I
whether I was transfer or as prime
minister I'd say exactly the same thing
but tax decisions are those that are
made by the chancellor in fiscal
statements and that's the way it should
be okay moving on to something that
definitely inside of those moving on to
something that's definitely in your
responsibility uh the refinancing of
Ukraine and the assets that we've
rightly sanctioned here in the UK what
is your view at this moment about how uh
the the UK can play a leading role in
helping to raise the finance to rebuild
Ukraine including that
um potentially of the Central Bank of
Russia uh I'll quick answer would be I
think we've played a leading role so far
through leveraging multilateral
Development Bank financing I think 1.25
billion has been unlocked from the World
Bank and others as a result of all
guarantees and other support that's
something we'll look to continue to look
to do more of and we're hosting a
reconstruction conference
this year thank you thank you very much
on with the cost of living crisis with
the work and pensions committee chair
Stephen Tims thank you chair
um to nobody's surprise Food Bank demand
Rose sharply last year and you're very
welcome decision to operate benefits
fully in line with inflation next April
will help make sure that doesn't get
significantly worse next year but you
said in the conservative party
leadership contest that you quote want
to build a country where ideally nobody
needs to use a food bank is that a
realistic Prospect do you think
as I'd like to think so and I think it's
as I said at the time happy to to repeat
it's uh you know it's sad that anyone
needs to use a food bank but at the same
time you know I'm grateful to the people
that provide those Services many of them
in our constituencies and and it's very
important and I'm grateful to them that
they do how long do you think it'll take
to end the need for food banks uh well I
you know I think we it's important for
us to get the economy growing again the
best way to do that is to have an
economy that's growing providing
opportunity for people and enable those
to support those who who can't work and
that's why all the other things we're
doing to strengthen our public finances
and reduce inflation is Paramount to get
into that point and in the short term
we've got a range of different support
for for people particularly with food
whether that's free School meals or
holiday activity and food program and
others that will help provide people
with the extra assistance particularly
this winter you envisage increasing
access preschool meals no I think our
free School meals policy is universal as
you know for for infants uh there's then
around 1.9 million who receive free
School meals beyond that extending to
Junior schools I think the provision we
have is the right provision but on top
of that we have the holiday activity and
food program which costs about 200
million pounds a year and provides food
and activity provision outside of turn
time also breakfast clubs that have been
rolled out across many schools which are
helping in the mornings but also
something called healthy staff vouchers
which don't get a lot of attention where
we increased by quite a significant
amount of value of those vouchers and
they they allow pregnant mothers or
indeed new mothers to get extra support
for fresh fruit and milk for example do
you anticipate Food Bank demand would
have reduced by the time of the next
election yeah I very I very much hope so
because I I hope that we can actually
get the economy growing
um over the course of the remainder of
this Parliament and and that's something
that I'll work very hard to do and do
you recognize that on the way to
eradicating really for food banks we
will need to improve the social security
safety net Beyond what's provided at the
moment well I think if you if you look
if you look at the stats and the income
inequality it's lower in the last
reported numbers than it was in 2010
there's over a million fewer people in
in poverty um
and uh several hundred thousand of your
workless households and ultimately the
surest route out of poverty is is not
for a child to grow up in a in a
workless household so actually I think
there's been enormous progress on on all
those fronts I think on food bank usage
in particular we need to get a better
understanding of it which is why I think
it's important that it's being included
for the first time in the DWP Family
Resources survey so we'll start to get
better data onto Bank usage which we
haven't had today
throughout all those things Food Bank
demand has continued to rise except then
you increase Universal value by 20 times
a week and then it did so that's why I
say I think that we will need to see an
improvement in the social security
safety net to achieve the the
eradication that you've you've held out
can I just mention a a couple of direct
current drivers of food bank demand
there's the local housing allowance is
Frozen at its 2020 level so when rent
goes up people have to dip into the rest
of their benefits to pay the rent and
disabled people people depending on
equipment have obviously much higher
electricity costs at the moment
and 290 000 people claiming disability
benefits have recently lost eligibility
to the warm homes discount scheme I
wonder if any of those three there are
there's any Prospect of further help
being provided but I would keep giving
short answers but on the local housing
allowance it was increased by a third
and that was worth about 600 and
very significant cash uplift at the time
which is appropriate to have then
maintained on on the warm homes discount
again from memory it was targeted to
actually properly targeted on those who
most needed help it was actually
increasing the mean I haven't got the
stats to hand it was increasing the
means testing of the benefit actually
delivering it to people who those needed
the help and I recognized the extra
costs of of those who need devices to
help them with disabilities which is why
one of the cost of living Pavements is
150 pounds to those in receipt of means
tested disability payments because that
will sit alongside the pension of
payment and the general cost of living
payment especially to take account of
the the fact that you just raised the
final point of imh that select midi is
published today a report on support for
child care costs in Universal Credit
you'll recognize that
supporting the costs of child care is a
big concern to NPC in your party and
across the house and at the moment the
maximum support for one child is capped
at the level that was first set in 2005
at 760 pounds per month
um isn't it high time that that cap was
upgraded
um I think as far as I recall it's
actually it's set at 85 percent of
eligible child care costs are
reimbursable so it's quite it's quite a
high threshold 85 percent but and I'm
talking to memory it is I don't have
this that and I'll have to get back to
Stephen I think there are very very few
people at the cap so I absolutely
appreciate the importance of child care
um I I'm not sure the cap is the thing
necessary to focus on because it affects
I think from memory a small number of
people but I happily have a look well
increasingly Rising
thank you
um could I bring Robin Walker the chair
of the education committee and very
briefly on the matter of Child Care
thank you chair prime minister you
yourself have said inactivity is one of
the big issues that has risen since your
time as Chancellor and one of the big
challenges we face would you agree that
better supporting Child Care is one of
the ways of conversing that bringing
people back into the workplace and
supporting people and with that in mind
the fact that the tax-free child care
which is supported by the treasury only
about one in five people who are
children who are eligible for child care
have taken it up and are those who've
opened accounts for tax-free child care
only about half of them are used is that
a concern for you yes I mean I started
working out when I was transfer that
work is ongoing how to improve the
take-up of the existing Child Care
offers which are not always well
understood and particularly tax-free
child care and the accounts as you
mentioned uh Robin that that work is
ongoing I think actually that they're
changing we're changing both the
promotional material how we explain
easy it is for people to access and what
they can use it on I think the just make
the office goal of course there's always
work to do we do have one of the um
lowest rate of inactivity among women
and actually
participation in a labor force in the UK
has gone up far more than most other
countries and other people ask us how
we've done it but there is of course
more to do which is why we continue to
refine and improve the challenge
thank you chairman just uh of the early
years become more and more important
part of Education our understanding of
the benefits of investment in the early
years has improved over time the ifs
recently confirmed that earlier spending
has actually gone up unlike other parts
of the
education spending over the last 10
years but do you think that trend is
likely to continue uh it's certainly if
I have anything to do with it I think
the early is very important and that's
why this chances are unprioritized
funding them in the last spending review
that I did particularly the work that
Andrea ledson had done I thought was uh
instructive and I've asked her to carry
on doing that and that work is being
rolled out across local authorities but
all the evidence is clear if we can
intervene earlier and support children
earlier it makes a big difference and we
can't reorient the system overnight but
incrementally directing more resource
there I think it's a good and sensible
thing to do
Catherine McKenna for the petitions
committee thank you chair
um just to pick you up on a comment that
you've made there about increasing
women's participation in the workforce
is he is he aware that in between the
ages of 25 and 39 the number of women
dropping out of the workforce is going
up not down and it's increasing and all
the progress that's been made over many
years in this country is actually going
backwards on that front so he should
look at those statistics very carefully
and there's also very clear statistics
that the number of mothers considering
leaving their jobs is quite significant
and many are cutting down their hours
due to the cost of child care and the
fact that ultimately many pay to work
and and this is obviously a significant
cost of the economy and prime minister
you mentioned earlier that there are you
know a tight labor market and this is a
difficult issue to solve might I suggest
that one way to solve it would be to
actually make it affordable for women to
stay in the workplace
yeah the point I was making which I
think stands is that if you look
internationally we rank as a country
with relatively high levels of female
participation in the labor force that
that is a fact of course there's always
work to do and it might well be that
it's moved down over the last year I
haven't got those numbers to hand but
internationally it's something that we
have done better than uh than others in
terms of the inactive and we'll continue
as I said already to continue looking at
our offers to see what more we can do
to support those who with child carrying
responsibilities to work if that's what
they want to do the inactivity problem
that we we're seeing most recently is
not as far as I am aware driven by an
increase in
Child Care is leaving the workforce it
is much more driven by those over 50 and
by an increase in Student Activity but
particularly the over 50s are the
biggest reason for the increase in
economic activity yeah because they have
caring responsibilities which is another
issue that needs to be addressed it's
not it's not obvious that they do it's
not a it's not a problem that is
completely well understood that it is a
mix of lifestyle decisions ill health
actually coming up and other reasons
it's not necessarily for caring
responsibilities and I mean just in
terms of your International ratings we
also rank one of the highest most
expensive Child Care Systems in the
world so he should also bear that in
mind just in relation to the Healthy
Start vouchers that he mentioned earlier
as a flagship announcement and scheme
and often mentioned by the government
but I've asked four times this year for
the take-up of that scheme since it was
digitized in April because a lot of
families expressed challenges around
managing the new digitized system I even
asked a treasury questions today they
couldn't give a figure does the Prime
Minister have a figure for how many
actually use the scheme I don't but I'd
happily write to the committee with the
answer good that would be helpful and
thank you is the prime minister author
aware that the petition committee led a
debate in Parliament yesterday on child
bed poverty that there's a teacher head
teacher Deputy head teacher in Leeds
who's established a charity to provide
beds for children because they're
struggling to concentrate at school is
he not ashamed that that is a reality
for children growing up in Britain today
sure is that we don't have children who
are growing up in poverty all the
evidence is crystal clear that the best
way to do that is to ensure that
children don't grow up in a workless
household and if you can achieve that
they're five times less likely to grow
up in poverty which is why I'm pleased
that there are several hundred thousand
fewer households that are like that
compared to when um
because the government first come into
office and that's why ensuring that we
can support people into good well-paid
jobs make sure
wage is really important because that is
the best way to ensure that children
don't grow up in poverty that's what I
want to see we've made great progress
there are hundreds of thousands fewer
children in poverty today than in 2010
but of course I want to keep keep
driving that number down so I just don't
recognize what the prime minister's
saying it seems to be a parallel reality
because the number of children living in
poverty is going up not down we're
heading for 34 by the government's own
measure preferred measure which
um is going to reach the peak of the
1990s so this is going in the wrong
direction which is why children are
going without beds it's a symptom of
child poverty
given that 75 of children growing up in
poverty live in a house where someone
works kind of Chancellor sorry prime
minister not see that it's a very
complacent response from him and it just
doesn't seem to be going to solve the
problem how is he going to solve child
poverty I I just I I maybe we'll look at
different numbers but the numbers that I
know and I believe I believe the
chairman of the committee here there are
as I said previously over a million
people fewer people fewer people in
absolute poverty than there were in 2010
uh now the children component of that I
think is 200 000 fewer children on that
measure and absolute poverty uh fewer
than there were in 2010 and again about
a million fewer workers households today
than in 2010 and again
that is by far and away I think the
biggest driver of a child growing up in
poverty I'm not remotely complacent
about it I don't want any child to grow
up in poverty uh it's awful decision
that they are and what we should do is
continue to reduce it we've made
progress there's always more to do I
think the most important way to help
those children is to make sure that
their parents are in good well-paid
shops
uh prime minister I'm sure you will join
me in Wishing Steve Ryan well who as
chair of the health committee should be
here but unfortunately he's been taken
ill with the flu and he's asked me to
ask his questions for him
um we meet on the day of the second
nurses strike and tomorrow of course we
have the ambulance industrial action the
government has stressed we have an
independent pay review process but
increasingly it seems to be something
the other political parties and
especially the trade unions don't
believe in
how big a problem do you think this is
and what do you propose to do about it
well it's worth bearing in mind that the
pay review bodies have been in existence
for a long time accepted by different
political parties as a sensible part of
the process and they were used by
previous labor governments as well and
other non-conservative politicians have
said that it would be right to cut
across the pay review bodies and they do
exist because payers is obviously
difficult and they exist to come to a
sensible considered and Fairview
balancing all the competing interests
about what reasonable and paid
settlements are and that's why the
government accepted them in full across
the board not just uh for the NHS and in
many cases those pay settlements were
more than what the government had
initially thought was
doable or and indeed high in many cases
and what was being offered in the
private sector so I think they are an
important part of the process and the
government has respected them
what reform of the pay review process
would you like to see
I I don't think I said I do want to see
a reform to it and
um is that something you would welcome
the health committee having a look at I
I wouldn't be for me to direct the
health committee to on their
investigations I wouldn't dream of doing
so
um but it sounds like a no
but I mean they are set up to balance I
mean the terms of reference are
relatively straightforward I mean
they're balancing what's affordable for
the taxpayer that's ultimately all these
things have to be paid for with the need
to make sure that we can recruit and
retain staff in the various sectors in
which they're operating those are I
don't think most people would quibble
with those
as as things for them to consider
inflation is also important was not just
important for us it's been important for
governments over the last few decades
and that's that's an important part of
what they do as well and the peer review
body will of course be looking again in
the new year at NHS pay and we'll report
to you in the summer and it now looks
inevitable that the process will provide
a much better offer to the NHS then
because of the inflation figures
um
is that on the agenda for change for
next year and with the promise of such
shouldn't the Royal College of nurses
actually call off their industrial
election now this winter while we
attempt to scale the covid backlog and
get the extra resources into social care
to ease discharge and therefore the very
real stress our ambulance crews are
facing on a daily basis
I think we've gone to inflation the pay
review bodies when they do make their
decisions are aware of what forward
estimates of inflation are and indeed
that was the case for this year's
estimates and for inflation which
already we're in we're in the evidence
and in their considerations and of
course you're right there will be a a
body and a process for next year which
among any other things the health
secretary has been clear our door is
always open to to talk to everybody and
be constructive about how we approach
these things in the future
um but that's uh look what I want to see
is you know the NHS that is able to
focus on reducing the backlogs improving
the quality and timeliness of care that
people are getting that's why we've put
billions of pounds of extra funding into
both the NHS and social careers as you
mentioned in the Autumn statement in
spite of the other difficult decisions
that needed to be made so I think that
represents a clear commitment from the
government to the importance of the NHS
making sure it's funded well but we do
need to make sure that money can
actually now go and deliver for patients
so in short what would be your personal
message this Christmas to NHS workers
and others who are taking strike action
or contemplating straight action as we
run up to Christmas I've always been
very clear in expressing my gratitude
and admiration for our NHS workers and
indeed our public sector workers across
the world for the job that they do I've
acknowledged that it is difficult it's
difficult for everybody because
inflation is where it is and the best
way to help them and to help everyone
else in the country is for us to get a
grip and reduce inflation as quickly as
possible and we need to make sure that
the decisions that we make can bring
about that outcome because if we get it
wrong and and we're still dealing with
high inflation in a year's time that's
not going to help anybody I don't want
to see that I want to see things get
back to normal and that's why having a
independent pay process is an important
part of us making those decisions and
getting them correct and that's why
we've accepted those recommendations in
film
well thank you prime minister I'm
impartial about the quality of your
answers but the brevity is good
and we're on time uh we're moving on to
the last section of our questions which
is we've called the state of the union
and it starts with the chairman of the
Scottish Affairs committee Pete Wishard
good to see you here and I think this
committee's disappointed we didn't get
the opportunity to maybe hear from your
predecessor such as the piece of events
over the course of the past few months
it's now been there four weeks since the
Supreme Court made its decision that the
Scottish Parliament didn't have the
necessary powers to legislate for a
Scottish independence referendum what
happens now
well as I say we respect the decision of
the Supreme Court and we'll continue to
focus on delivering to the people of
Scotland and working constructively with
the Scottish government to do that well
what has happened of course is that
there's now six opinion pools and a rule
that shows majority support for Scottish
independence and if there was a
Independence referendum tomorrow I think
would be a very good chance that
Scottish independence would win so again
I ask you how do we take this forward
how do we start to resolve this
situation I don't think you're expecting
that those of us who support Scottish
independent should take our Ambitions
for Nations away so what is the UK
government going to do to respond to
this issues this sessions called State
of the Union it's certainly in a state
when one part of it seems to want the
option of leaving this Union
well I I am going to continue delivering
for the people of Scotland I think we've
talked about all the issues that the
country is grappling with whether it's
inflation the cost of living
more than anything else but also making
sure that we can have health services
that are responsive to people's needs
protecting our energy security standing
up to Russian aggression you know these
are all really important issues and I
think you know many of them we can and
will continue to work constructively
with the Scottish government to make a
difference to people's lives so that's
very much my focus and that's what I'll
continue to do do you realize just how
hollow and awful that response sounds to
the situations Scotland as well I mean
we want to resolve this democratically
we believe the Scottish people should
decide the future I think that's how
most nations would approach this issue
even the labor party have their own new
constitutional plans to bring It Forward
I think the Liberals still believe in
federalism across the UK you're not
going to sit there and tell me you have
no plans to deal with some of the
Constitutional difficulties issues that
nurses colleges now surely you must have
some sort of plan other than all the
other things that you're going to be
doing anyway well actually I mean one
thing that we're very keen to make sure
we deliver is all the recommendations of
the Smith
which represented a significant transfer
of power responsibility to the Scottish
government which is probably the most
powerful devolved Parliament anywhere in
the world uh the Scotland act 2016 set
out all of those and we want to work
constructively with the Scottish
government to deliver on all of those as
we are making good progress on and that
represents as I said one of the biggest
transfers of power that anyone has ever
seen and that's that that's the UK
government respecting the commitments
that it made and delivering them so
we've all been asking you this from you
all the way down to your senior
ministers to the secretary from Scotland
we've all asked what do we do know how
do we actually do this forward how do we
start to accommodate the legitimate
requirements of the Scottish people when
it comes to disabled constitutional
future we've not had any answers but
again we're not getting any answers at
all the only thing we've had to think is
from the secretary state from Scotland
who said we'll just know when we get
there when the conditions will be right
and they gave the famous duck tests if
it looks like Adult World they could you
know the rest of the Prime Minister is
that what it is is that that is that
what we've got to wait for until you
decide that the conditions are right for
the Scottish people to have this
opportunity to recite the prostitutional
future no I I look my belief is that the
Scottish people would like their
governments both the Scottish government
and the UK government to focus on the
issues that are most pressing at the
moment given the scale of the challenges
that we face you know I've been very
clear that I want to do that in a
constructive manner I want to work in
Partnership where they've got with the
Scottish government where we can and I
think we can make a difference to
people's lives that's why I called the
first Minister very shortly after
assuming office is why I attended the
British Irish Council that brings
together everyone from across our
Islands
place to discuss these issues and you
know I will continue to operate in that
spirit and hopefully make a difference
on these issues that matched people at
this time so here's something else we'll
offer you see if you could agree with
this or not that the more you put
variety on this the more you start to
see the Lord your failure to engage into
the legitimate demands of the Scottish
people the only thing that's going to
happen surely is support for
Independence is going to continue to
grow up and at some point you're going
to have to sit down and deal with that I
thought you just deal with that just now
why don't you bring forward the
necessary change in the legislation so
we could do this because the other
option surely is support for
Independence is going to go up and at
some point you're going to have to
address this you do realize that don't
you well what what I'm focused on is
actually making a difference to the
lives of people in Scotland the
challenges they face first and foremost
are with the cost of living and the
impact that's having on them you know I
want to do everything I can to try and
alleviate some of those burdens and
provide opportunity and jobs for them
and I think we can do a lot of that in
partnership with the Scottish government
when we work constructively together and
that's what I'm going to keep doing and
I think that's the right thing to do
well I think the Scottish people will be
listening to these proceedings and will
be very disappointed that you can't even
offer one scenario where you're going to
engage positively with what the Scottish
people seem to want but just lastly from
me sir berners that's all right like
you're the only senior government
Minister that was given the fixed
penalty notice during party games the
the other recipient of one of course is
facing the Privileges committing with
some very serious sanctions do you think
that we've been unnecessarily hard on
your predecessor but one or maybe two
years on yourself yeah I mean I've I've
addressed that in the past so I haven't
got anything further to add I wouldn't
wouldn't be my pleased to comment on the
which obviously independent from
government but I would just say you
disagree with something you said before
that what Scottish people will see about
engaging positively that's exactly what
we are doing we are engaging positively
with the Scottish government that's why
I call the first Minister shortly after
taking office and then on the first day
it's why I went to to see her and other
devolved leaders very shortly after
taking office the first UK prime
minister to attend that Gathering since
2007. I think that serves as a
demonstration that I do want to engage
positively to make a difference
just recently and when I was Chancellor
we made sure that we can invest directly
in Scottish communities through the
leveling up fund that those Investments
are making a real difference on the
ground for those communities and I think
that's an example of what we could do
and I'm going to keep doing more of it
I'd just like to point out the
references to the Privileges Community
have nothing to do with fixed penalty
notices they're about a completely
separate matter
as a member of the Privileges committee
I think I'm entitled to say that Joanna
cherry
afternoon prime minister in September
the current Home Secretary taught a
fringe event at your party conference
that ultimately the United Kingdom would
need to leave the European convention on
human rights and last week when we had
the Deputy Prime Minister and Lord
Chancellor in front of the joint
committee on human rights I asked him
about his position on the convention and
he said and I quote the government's
position is very clear We Rule nothing
out nothing is off the table for the
future so can you confirm whether you
agree with your Home Secretary and
whether the Deputy Prime Minister
accurately described the position of
your government to my committee yeah I
mean I've been very clear as I said
previously
I want to deliver an immigration system
which means that when someone comes here
illegally they don't have the right to
stay and we will be able to return them
either to their own country where it's
safe or a say Third Country alternative
where that makes sense and it will
introduce the legislation next year and
I'm confident we can deliver on the
system that I wanted to be put in place
but what I asked you is whether the Home
Secretary is correct to see ultimately
you're required to leave the the
convention
as I said we'll put in place the
legislation next year and I'm sure we'll
be discussing it at the time do you
disagree with her I said I I don't think
I was in government at the time but she
made the comment so I'm not familiar
with it but what I can tell you is the
system that I'm going to deliver as
prime minister that I'm working with the
Home Secretary on and we'll you'll see
the legislation next year and no doubt
we will have the opportunity to debate
it then but I wouldn't want to speculate
on that now well despite the high
turnover of prime ministers you were in
government last week when the Deputy
Prime Minister told me that it wasn't
off the table is that correct leaving
the convention is not off the table for
your government I said no I want to fix
this problem right and I'm going to do
everything that I need to to fix the
problem of illegal migration and small
boats come in here and we'll introduce
legislation in the new year that will
help us do that as I said there's lots
of different things we need to do
legislation is a part of it Rwanda is a
part of it our approach to Albania is a
part of it and but you know I'm
confident that we can deliver all of
these things
when will the bill British Bill of
Rights bill have a second reading I
don't have a specific date as with all
these things it's been parliamentary
time allows has it been de-prioritized
in order to allow you to concentrate on
the new immigration legislation you've
just mentioned I I know as well I'm a
new prime minister you would expect me
to look at the entire legislative
program and and then make decisions on
that basis you know some things that we
need to do sooner rather than later and
and as it is for example with Northern
Ireland where we had to make decisions
because of the lack of a functioning
executive that meant that legislation
had to be introduced at that time not
something I was anticipating beforehand
so those are the types of things that
come up that you know we're keen to
deliver on illegal migration and that's
something that I said is a priority
Bill of Rights bill is very much Dominic
Brad's baby very much his pet project if
the allegations of bullying against him
which are currently being investigated
are found to be true and he has to
resign would that be the end of the Bill
of Rights I don't even expect me to
comment on either that I would just
point out it was also a manifesting
commitment to update the Human Rights
Act
but it wasn't a manifest or commitment
to repeal and replace the Human Rights
Act was there you know there's lots of
different ways of doing it but I'm
making the broader point that a
commitment to update to update the Human
Rights Act you know was there from 2019
yeah but my point is that Dominic Rab's
bill doesn't update the Human Rights Act
it repeals it and replaces it with
something else so are you seeing that
the option of Simply updating it still
on the table I was making the broader
point that that's where the the Genesis
of the the policy comes from but there
are some very practical sensible things
that it
it would be good I think everyone
hopefully would agree you know whether
that's deporting more foreign National
offenders who are using their articulate
right to a family life to stop being
deported whether that's
convicted terrorists in prisons who are
somehow able to use their right to
socialize to stop being separated from
other prisoners where we think actually
that will cause more radicalization and
indeed was the recommendation from an
independent reviewer of of
counterterrorism for us so you know
where we're not able to deliver on those
very sensible policy things because of
the way the HRI is being interpreted it
seems entirely reasonable to look at how
better to resolve those will your new
immigration laws contain any provisions
deregating from the European convention
on human rights again I'm not I'm not
going to speculate on future legislation
now but I'm going to introduce
legislation next year that will deliver
on the immigration system that I want to
see which is if someone comes here
illegally that we will have the right to
remove them
to either their own country or a safe
Third Country alternative they should
not have the ability to stay here that's
I think quite frankly a common sense
position that is held by the vast
majority of British people and that's
the system that I wanted to deliver the
convention and the Human Rights Act are
woven into the Scotland act which
established the Scottish Parliament and
my committee's heard expert evidence
that a consent motion will be required
from the Scottish Parliament before the
Human Rights Act could be repealed and
indeed our cross-party committee of MPS
and peers has recommended that you
shouldn't proceed without that consent
now you made greatly to my colleague
Pete Wishard a moment ago about your new
agenda with the Scottish government and
when you took over as prime minister you
said you wanted to reset the
relationship between Westminster and
holyrood and that the union between
Scotland and England should be
collaborative and constructive so in
that spirit will you respect the vote of
the Scottish Parliament if it will
withholds consent to the repeal of the
Human Rights Act yeah well I want to
make sure that we work through this your
convention process is that there is good
engagement and constructive dialogue and
that's what we will try and do yeah but
if the outcome of the process is the
withholding of consent will you respect
that in the spirit of collaboration and
constructive engagement that you've
planned I I don't I don't think anyone
would expect all governments across the
United Kingdom to agree on absolutely
everything that where we can where we
can work collaboratively constructively
together we will do and even where we
disagree it's right to have engagement
about those things that's the approach
that I will take very shortly you said a
moment ago that the Scottish Parliament
was the most powerful devolved
Parliament anywhere in the world
wouldn't you expect such a powerful
devolved Parliament to be able to
protect human rights laws woven into its
foundation document you know I'd expect
the story of parliament to continue
delivering for its people on the things
that matter whether that's you know
schools or policing and working with the
UK government where it makes sense
the Prime Minister would you welcome
proposals from anybody on how to deliver
your objective of being able to
either send people back to their home
country or send people back to a safe
country if they arrive up arrive here
illegally
um from for example the human rights
committee or the SNP or the labor party
would you consider those proposals I I I
think I'm I'm always happy to to hear
proposals uh chair and there's no
shortage of them coming my way I've
discovered so I don't think anyone needs
an invitation from me to give me their
opinion
um Sir William cash are from the
European secretion the European Union
excrucially committed we still have much
European law in our system
yes a prime minister
um our statute book in the United
Kingdom is still really seriously
effective by accumulated and current EU
law even though we've less left the EU
the European scrutiny committee has
found this deeply disturbing and the
interaction between our own statutes and
European statutes includes our own
Current Online safety building and the
European Union's own Digital Services
Act
this is there is an urgent need in
particular for the protection of our
children and our grandchildren in
relation to this monstrous and Evil
State of Affairs which is now stalking
the land
uh where there is child child sexual
abuse and exposure of those children to
harmful content online
I'm sure this is a matter of grave
concern to you as well
this is combining to destroy young
people's lives and their families even
driving
some children to Suicide such as in the
tragic case of Molly Russell and the
inquest pre that was the case
there's massive secrecy as we now know
through Lobby documents which have
recently been released by the corporate
European Observatory and the Freedom of
Information procedures
within those institutions and the
procedural Labyrinth of the EU including
the dialogue system with big Tech firms
recently spending more than 27 million
pounds on lobbying in just one year not
only in the EU itself but also here
we've tabled and are now drafting
further amendments to our Online safety
Bill to impose personal criminal
liability
on those and including imprisonment for
those senior managers who willfully fail
to comply with their statutory safety
duties and who by the abuse of their
platforms and algorithms
fail to protect children from online
harm
in this matter we are fully supported by
the nspcc and by other children's
charities and by very many MPS
across the floor of the house in the
National interest
can I ask you this please
do you appreciate the nature and the
scale of this problem and would you
therefore Meet myself and others in the
first week of the new year
before the report stage on the 16th of
January
to ensure that our own Online safety
bill is amended
to include the concept of safety
controllers and so that senior directors
and managers will be made personally and
criminally responsible if their service
fails to comply with children's safety
duties which has resulted in profound
tragedy and harm to our children
whatever the European Union has itself
decided to legislate for itself will you
please give me some
clear understanding that you will
support the proposals of the nspcc and
myself and others in this in this matter
well first I think this is a really
important piece of legislation for
exactly the reasons that you outline
Seville at the moment are you know our
children are not as safe as they deserve
a need to be online and our bill I think
is a world leading piece of legislation
that's been designed to ensure that
large tech companies take more
responsibility for the safety of their
users particularly children their strong
Protections in their
for our children they've been welcomed
by stakeholders across the board and to
your point on the powers that we have to
hold them to account ofcom will now be
able to find them and will be able to
find them up to 10 of their Global
turnover which is obviously very
significant it can obviously direct them
to make specific improvements and to
their platforms that can force a con
Force third-party services to remove
content and Senior managers are under
the bill already able to face criminal
sanctions if their company doesn't
comply with ofcom's requirements I know
the culture secretary has been engaging
with with all parties widely the bill
has been widely supported not just by
all the former secretaries and state but
by children's groups and others and and
I say something that we are leading the
world in
sure she'll continue to engage with
colleagues as the bill makes its way
through Parliament but then to accept
the premise from which I've set out the
question I put to you in asking you if
you would meet with us to discuss these
matters it was unfortunately there is a
seriously kuna here and the criminal
responsibility to which you refer is one
stage removed it is not direct and it
does not deal with the problem as nspcc
and others are clearly stated okay I'm
sure the culture sector will continue to
engage on the specific detail but as I
said the principle of the bill as far as
I understand it and what we want to
achieve is that senior managers could
face criminal sanctions if the company
doesn't comply with ofcom's uh
particularly information requirements
but I happily have the cultures entry
and pick that up
so prime minister something to look
forward to in the new year a meeting
with Sir William cash I'll I will I will
get I will get the call Secretary to
pick it up immediately thank you very
much and uh thank you sir William uh so
Bob Neal for the Justice committee
good to see you prime minister
how seriously do you take the
government's obligation under the
Constitutional Reform Act to uphold the
independence of the Judiciary and to
provide adequate resource for the
efficient discharge of the justice
system
um of course I'm committed to the
independence
absolutely a Cornerstone of how I see
the world and you're right about
resourcing
I think we're investing about 138
million pounds additionally into the
criminal legal aid sector for example
and we've already implemented I think a
15 increase to most fee schemes I know
it's something that you've thought about
and mentioned in in the past and I think
in some it will mean that our criminal
legal aid lawyers will receive the
biggest boost to their compensation in
in some decades would you accept as a
situation where despite that investment
which I recognize that people can be
waiting for two years for a serious
sexual offense case can be heard or a
small business from wait 18 months but
for a money claim or a contract dispute
to be dissolved it is not really
efficient yeah we absolutely have a
challenge with the backlog in our court
system I think
we were making progress as a result of
covid let's be clear and that's why the
spending review
um in 2021 we allocated almost half a
billion extra pounds over the rest of
parliament to try and get those backlogs
down we were making progress until the
the Barrister's strike but we need to
now obviously redouble our efforts some
of the things we are doing is recruiting
up to a thousand new judges and removing
the limit on sitting days and also
providing more support for remote
hearings and the continued operation of
Nightingale courts I think all of those
initiatives will help us move through
the backlog you're absolutely right
though we want people to have Swift and
timely access to justice so this
deserves our attention and it's getting
it I believe you're due to meet the Lord
Chief Justice of England Wales in the
new year would he make a point of
particularly listening to the concerns
he has raised with the Justice committee
about the senior Judiciary pattern about
the delays and pressures on the system
as it currently stands yeah I look
forward to meeting him and
sensation do you also accept that legal
certainty is important for British
business and for investment in the UK
yes I think that you're right actually
as well about that it's not just the
individuals but for business as well
it's important timely Justice and
certainty how does a provision that
would automatically cause over two three
thousand Pieces perhaps of retained EU
legislation to expire automatic at the
end of 2023 as currently proposed add to
business certainty
well I I think on on that point it's
it's right that we look at the stock of
retained e-law that we've got and make
sure that we as a UK Parliament have
decided what we want to keep what we
want to flex and change uh you know and
I want to move on with that as quickly
as possible now you know there there are
some Provisions in the bill as you know
for flexibility around doing that but I
do think it's right that we make
progress on this but are you some
flexibility on the time limit no but
it's about making sure it's it's about
making sure that we can do this properly
which is what we're going to do I think
you know the referendum was about
several years ago I think it's
appropriate that we look at our statute
book and say hang on which bits of these
that we we grandfathered in deliberately
at the time for practicality you know
which bits of these do we actually think
are right for the UK and it may well be
that bits of them are and that will be
straightforward but there will certainly
be areas and particularly in those areas
of our economy where we want to see
growth whether that's in life sciences
or Digital Data Technical Services as
we're reforming already in Professional
Services where we will want to take
advantage of the new flexibilities and
sovereignty we have to do things
differently to create opportunities in
this country I think that's really
important in demonstrating some of the
benefits of the freedoms that we have
for brexit but I I believe we need to do
it quickly to provide uncertainty that
you're right people should expect it
does quickly mean arbitrarily or is it
just doing it thoroughly no we could do
it we should do it quickly and
thoroughly um but I think you know look
what people are should be focused on and
what are the practical changes that
we're going to make that will make
things better in the UK that's what I'm
focused on I'm focused on being able to
say here are the things that we're going
to change and these are the benefits
that will flow from them what one point
if I make and that's this
you've referred when you're being prime
minister to delivering on our 2019
Manifesto equipment our 2019 Manifesto
equipment has already been referred to
in the order update human rights and
administrative law and of course it made
no mention no suggestions at all
whatever he was a convention I don't
think you've ever stressed the Prime
Minister had to have you you know what
the reason I think the reason we're
having this conversation is with regards
specifically to Illegal migration and
I I'm clear about the system that I want
to deliver and you know
lots of theories people will have but
the example I put people to is that of
Albania yes and people said well you
know you have to leave these HR if you
want to fix this problem I made the
point that hang on
lots of other European countries in fact
the vast majority of them all reject
close to 100 of Albanian cases So at
their system of trees to ecat they're
all signatories so they must be able to
fix the problem we have with illegal
migrants yeah in terms of updating and I
take your point I agree with you in
terms of updating and saying within the
Convention as those countries have will
you have another look at the report by
Sir Peter Gross on the independent
review of The Human Rights Act which
suggested updating and a number of
specific changes in the areas including
those which you and I have just been
discussing around migration extra
territoriality and other practical
events is a potential Way Forward I will
I will I'm going to defer to your
expertise on this um I think you know
I'm grateful to Sir Peter is for
Hannah's panel in fact actually
and I know the Justice secretary and
government have considered the report in
producing its own consultation in this
area which I know probably will be more
familiar with than I probably am but I
think we're taking on board some of the
spirit of this of the suggestions for
example emphasis on common law but I'll
happily take that I'll take it as well
forgive me I've got to let some other
people in first I'll let you in at this
time Philip Dunn
white prime minister in relation to a
department whether which is at risk of
overload because of the backlog of work
and that's within defra you announced
recently that you're intending to extend
current session of parliament until
Autumn 2023 one of the pieces of
legislation which is expected to be
concluded during the course of 2023 is
the retained EU law revocational Reform
Bill that includes a vast number of
pieces of legislation custom stemming
from the EU relating to the environment
there is no Clarity at this point as to
uh where the process of reviewing those
laws has got to and therefore there's a
lot of concern that there may be some
wholesale changes to environmental law
undertaken a short notice of little
ability for either house of parliament
to review them could you give us some
clarity and about the timetable for that
Bill about the extent to which the defra
ministerial team could be directed to
start working within the department and
give some reassurance that the
environmental Provisions are not going
to be disturbed wholesale
yes um we've already committed Philip I
think during the second reading of the
royal bill that the bill would not
weaken Environmental Protections right
so that commitment has already been made
you know what we want to do is use the
powers in the bill to ensure that our
own environmental law is functioning and
able to drive the continued improved
environmental outcomes that you and I
think everyone wants to see and making
sure that the UK regulatory framework is
tailored and appropriate for our own
country I think I could also just look
at the proof points we've already
introduced Fisheries act agriculture act
environment act those are all ambitious
reforms to all those areas post-leading
the EU which I think we've done
successfully in
leading in many cases and we've already
repealed over 140 bits of retained EU
law
in the deferest space particularly the
European Fisheries controlling Agency
for example now in terms of process from
here there's a public dashboard I think
that defra put in place they're working
through it and we expect that dashboard
to be updated in the new year to to rep
to reflect the full extent of the rule
regulations that we think are in are in
scope I'm looking forward to continue
working with you and others to make sure
that we get this right
on this subject one Minister told me
that officials are being constrained
from drafting replacement regulations
and Consulting on them because they're
not allowed to do that until the
legislation is on the statute book
can I suggest that you should authorize
departments to start Drafting and
Consulting on the replacement regulation
from now so that as soon as the statute
is approved they can get on with the
Parliamentary process of scrutinizing
all this stuff because that's where the
bottleneck is going to going to exist
yes I I will certainly take take that
away
is a there's a body of work to be done
um thank you Robin Walker
yeah as a member of the Northern Ireland
Affairs committee I particularly welcome
the fact that you did attend the British
Irish Council and I think that was
important there are strong rumors that
the UK and EU are working towards a
Valentine's Day agreement on the
protocol are you confident that an
agreement will be in place in time for
the institutions of the Good Friday
agreement to be back up and running for
the very important anniversary next year
Well I you know I've been clear actually
that I hadn't put an arbitrary or strict
deadline on the conversations that we're
having I don't think that that's
necessarily helpful and I don't want to
you know necessarily raise people's
expectations and even a breakthrough you
know what I am committed to doing is
working constructively with our European
Partners to see if we can find a way
through this to resolve the very clear
challenges that the protocol presents to
Northern Ireland's place in the union I
want to see those problems fixed it's a
fixed I want to protect Northern
Ireland's place in the Union
I'm a foreign secretary met with the
within sefcoish just recently and those
talk to ongoing
thank you and one issue that affects
every part of the UK and in the
education space is the the issue of
international students as being a recent
suggestions that there could be some
kind of a Crackdown or reduction in the
numbers and yet when I visited
universities whether it's Queen's
Belfast Cardiff Glasgow or indeed
Worcester they all value the
international students both the economic
and cultural benefits that they bring I
remember when I was at the DFE we
celebrated hitting the Milestone the
target of 600 000 International students
as a an unequivocally good thing do you
think that is a target we should
continue to pursue do you think we
should go further or do you think there
is actually some reason to reduce the
numbers
no I just I first I think International
students do make a significant economic
and cultural contribution to the UK's
higher education sector and indeed the
UK I think they enrich the university
experience for all students actually and
it's a good thing and I think the point
just to recognize is the Target that we
set of 600 000 was for 2030 and you know
we've met it several years earlier I
think that's
you know some sort of sign of success
but obviously it just causes one to look
at the situation but you know no one is
doubting the contributions that their
students make to the UK and the economy
and do you agree given all our
universities our Elite institutions the
suggestions of only allowing some to
welcome International students and not
others is a non-starter
we attract the best and the brightest to
the UK that's something that we would
always want to do and
uh the Talon and we want to make sure
actually fun enough our Visa system for
highly skilled people is very
competitive that those are the the
reforms that we've put in place will
always continue to attract people here
we just want to make sure that people
when they're here are contributing one
way or another I think that's important
foundation of a proper migration system
thank you Brian so finally there's a
briefing that you're looking at a
British Baccalaureate for uh post 16
um given we're talking about the Union
uh what conversations have there been
with the devolved administrations about
that given that education is wholly
demult in Northern Ireland Scotland and
Wales uh and we call this British
baccalaureates if it's England yeah I
think that the main focus of as a
secretary of state I think probably uh
said previously at the select committee
is about looking at maths actually is
something that I've spoken about in the
past and you know we are an outlier
country in
lack of maths study after 16 compared to
almost everyone else and we we certainly
lag behind
numeracy when it comes to young adults
or we significantly lag behind the oecd
average and given how important that is
for people's opportunities in life
and their ability to have good jobs I
think it's worth us looking at that and
seeing you know whether we've got things
as we would like them if we're really
focused on making sure that our children
our grandchildren have a fantastic
future ahead of them
thank you I should have just mentioned
that Mr Walker's standing in for the
chair of the Northern Ireland committee
who couldn't be here today and he serves
in the north county as well as chairing
the education committee how he finds the
time for that I don't know Well Done
um Catherine mckennell thank you chair
and given you said it'll be one of the
first things that you do and you've
already out like outlasted the last
prime minister where is your independent
ethics advisor yes I'm hopeful I can
make an announcement on that on that
soon you know and it's important to me
to get someone I think is is right for
the job and you know rest assured I'm
I'm hard at it and I said I hopefully we
can have an announcement soon okay
um
and
I appreciate you can't comment on
ongoing legal proceedings but do you
regret ignoring the warnings about lack
of basic checks which have estimate and
resulted an estimated 6.7 billion pounds
of public money being wasted to fraud on
Covert contracts
extensively uh in in the house and in
the interest of finishing our time to
keep my answer sure that there's
absolutely no tolerance for people
who've recorded the system it's wrong
particularly at a time of Crisis and
they will be a relentlessly and
rigorously pursued as they already are
being they've had dozens and dozens of
arrests billions of pounds recovered and
specialist agencies set up to to go
after people who have perpetrated this
but I would say that the newest
estimates of fraud across some of the
schemes during coronavirus are now not
only have they reduced by a third from
where they were they're now either in
line or lower than the fraud that you
would expect from a typical government
program and considering the speed and
scale at which they were implemented
actually is um is positive but there's
obviously work to do and we will keep
going after this the question was do you
do you regret ignoring the warnings I I
I actually I don't think that's the
right characterization at the time if
anything then I could at the interest of
time I won't go into it I could Regale
you with many quotes from many
politicians from all parties about how
we weren't going fast enough in removing
checks and bureaucracy from businesses
pressure on one thing when you were a
Chancellor you lost a minister in the
Lord
who was very clear that he did not feel
that this was being treated seriously
enough in the clearing up operation what
has changed since then actually many of
the things that he mentioned are already
happening whether it's a new public
sector for all authority more resources
into the crime fighting agencies more
arrests a dashboard but something that
he was particularly concerned about
which was already being implemented
which is important for comparability of
Statistics across different lenders for
example and recovery and bounce back
loads of all those types of things are
actually were being implemented and are
being implemented right we are now a
miniature over time but please could you
give us time for two one-liners Joanna
cherry
you mentioned British Baccalaureate
there I'm not saying it's a bad idea but
it would of course be an English
Baccalaureate wouldn't it because
education is fully devolved and Scottish
students already do a wider range of
subjects at their higher level than in
England
yes as I said the focus is on why Focus
was looking at maths yeah but my point
is it wouldn't be a British
Baccalaureate it would be an English one
because education is fully devolved to
the Scottish Parliament I'm not happy to
talk about that or I was just talking
about actually people studying more
maths after the age of 16 that doesn't
mean it's in a baccalaureate there's
lots of different ways people would you
accept my point yeah it was the same
point that Robin made no it's not it's a
different point my point was if there
was to be a British Baccalaureate it
would not be a British Baccalaureate it
would be an English one because
education is fully devolved in Scottish
Department it's not a trick question
prime minister it's just no I mean I
think it's a it's a statement of fact
and I think it's the same point that
Robert made I wasn't difficult if it's
disagreeing with it it's actually a
shorthand that people use because of the
alliteration for having a broader
qualification I don't think it's meant
to be in any way a reflection on the
Devolution settlement I I literally
think that's all it was and I was
talking about math personally yeah but
my point is and I think you've made your
point yeah either Sherry
um Alicia Kearns last question the
original integrated review failed to
reference Taiwan explicitly despite XI
jinping's clear intention the fact that
40 of all global trade goes through the
South China Seas if you include America
straight as well 80 of your
semiconductor chips produced and the
fact that if there was an illegal
Invasion the effect on the worldwide
economy would truly be crippling so can
you please assure us that there will be
explicit reference to Taiwan within the
IR refresh because otherwise we are not
learning the lesson of Ukraine where
Putin told us time and time again it was
going to invade him which didn't believe
it alongside the need to recreate the
current situation the Balkans where we
see escalating conflict between cerber
and Kosovo and the undermining the
sovereignty of Bosnia Herzegovina where
we have explicit commitment and
requirements to uphold peace and
security there all noted
that's not a yes though is it I'm not
going to write the IR right here and now
but you have all the things all things
that you would expect I would go over as
we're refreshing it prime minister
you've
um not been as generous with your time
as your predecessors but we're very very
grateful you manage to visit us in
before Christmas and
um uh you've also answered the questions
very very fully
um whether satisfactorily or not isn't
automatically but thank you very very
much and I'm sure the committee would
like to wish you and your family a very
good Christmas and I certainly wish the
rest of my committee a good Christmas as
well
thank you Merry Christmas
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended